tell me you talk about audiences and how
they could be quite difficult and was it
the Royal Shakespeare Company you had a
doozy when you were on stage
doozy doozy okay a bad audience
experience oh you did a doozy on the
stage it means you've got a weak pelvic
floor it doesn't we did they show it it
Stratford we did much to do about
nothing and it came into town into
London for a little run and there's this
is a fantastic play is very funny and
very dark it's very dark there's a
central scene in it where my my
characters younger cousin is is
disabused in at the wedding altar at her
own wedding and and then afterwards I go
mad and say - I plain [ __ ] listen I was
saying to Benedict if you really love me
then you have to kill him you have to
kill this man who's just a speech my
cousin and it's a really dark I'm
beautiful very serious scene and I had
all this kerfuffle in the audience
lots of noise I was furious
absolutely how dare they these children
come in here these days we were studying
it for education just calm down and just
pay attention and but we carried on
gamely and then i found out afterwards
that there was a young lad who'd felt
very sick and projectile vomited the
people always made teacher on there and
he was trying to get out if you think
and he had to sit there with this woman
maybe a little worse than sitting him
behind in front of your knees when I was
at a wedding once and it during the
ceremony was a big church and during the
ceremony a little boy do you know what
do you take this woman Birla and this
little boy jumped up and started running
down the sort of aisle tripped vomited
everywhere III went on a school trip to
the House of Lords this is I like I did
you wanna involve sonship the coach they
are taking one not feeling well they
finally find it fun in the house of lots
I went I thought if I just go very still
and swallows I'm so sorry it really
Lord's in all over the red velvet seat
and my teacher to turn around say
disgusting with wipes no no it's cool I
thought this was like
I know have you vomit it makes you shine
yourself what what's going on I think
it's coming
[Music]
you